تقترب شركات الأدوية
من خط النهاية ،
فهناك أكثر من 170 لقاحًا مرشحًا
حول العالم ،
وثمانية منهم في المرحلة النهائية من التجارب البشرية
التي تثبت فعاليتهم في الأمان وأن
الحصول على الموافقة التنظيمية
ليس هو التحدي الوحيد الذي يتعين علينا الانتقال إليه
من هناك
إلى  لدينا بالفعل مليارات الجرعات من
اللقاح
التي يمكن توصيلها إلى الأشخاص في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، نحن
نستثمر في عملية
التصنيع
قبل أن نعرف حتى ما إذا كان لقاح معين
سيصل إلى الترخيص ويمكن استخدامه
، وقد خصصت الحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم
مليارات الدولارات
يشتري صانعو اللقاحات مئات الملايين من
جرعات اللقاح
التي قد لا تعمل حتى
شركة فايزر بالشراكة مع
خطط التكنولوجيا الحيوية لجعل 100 مليون جرعة من
اللقاح المرشح بحلول نهاية العام
وأكثر من مليار جرعة تالية
ليس طبيعيًا على الإطلاق.
حاول وتلبية هذا الطلب أنشأت viza
تصنيعًا منفصلاً في الولايات المتحدة
وأوروبا
وتعتمد على كل ما لديها  الموارد هذا
حقًا جهد تعاوني
يجب أن يكون كما تعلم في هذه الحالة
أه السباق صحيح أن الناس يتحدثون
عن
المنافسة بشكل صحيح لأن المنافسة ليست بعضها على
حق ، إنها
تعمل حقًا ضد الفيروس مما يجعل
اللقاح
ليس '  في نهاية التحدي ،
ننتقل إلى أولئك الذين يحتاجون إليه في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
تخطط شركات مثل bps لتكون جاهزة
للاستلام من
المتجر وتقديم لقاح ناجح
لا نعرف من سيكون أولًا ،
فنحن نعلم أن شركة pfizer moderna  astrazeneco
مع جامعة أكسفورد
نحن نعلم أن cancino في الصين
يعمل بشكل جيد ونحن نعلم أن novovax
تتحرك بسرعة
أنواع مختلفة من اللقاحات تحتاج إلى ظروف
نقل وتخزين مختلفة
واحدة من أكبر التحديات هي
درجة الحرارة التي تجعل اللقاح
آمنًا وآمنًا أمرًا بالغ الأهمية وخطط UPS
لدينا 24 7 تتبع لكل
قارورة واحدة ،
نحن نأخذ على محمل الجد حقيقة
أن عملائنا
يعتمدون علينا لتحريك كل
قارورة واحدة ولا نفقد واحدة
ليسوا وحدهم ، وهم ليسوا بمفردهم من مطوري اللقاحات
، يتخذ المصنعون وشركات الخدمات اللوجستية
إجراءات غير مسبوقة ليس
فقط لصنع لقاح للـ 19.
آنا ستيوارت سي إن إن لندن